and then there's women like Molin who
need your help
so for you to get what if these shores
[Music]
so this is where the work for bottom
women becomes real with all your
donations and support that have been
flooding in we wanted to show you
exactly what's happening and the lives
that we're transforming we're building
kiosks to be able to give it to these
women's create businesses for themselves
that's providing an education food
housing and rebuilding their lives and a
whole to be better equipped to deal with
anything that's thrown at them and as I
said before that it's a huge success
rate for these women and it's impactful
and the fact that we can come together
we've forgotten women to provide this
it's just so important and it's a whole
family that then goes on to have a
better future and a better life and we
deserve that whatever country were in so
please keep helping keep donating
because this is really happening
and we're really transforming lives now
and for the better so this is what I
serve the lady that inspired this whole
project and we've come to visit her
quickly before we leave tomorrow and we
are so happy to say that all her drinks
are gone due to a local wedding and this
for us is what it's all about so we're
here
[Music]
[Music]
women around the world in places like
Pakistan India Bangladesh and Africa are
currently suffering trapped in the cycle
of poverty with no means of escape to
support your other mother initiative was
designed to offer women the opportunity
to develop their independence and
protect their dignity the women in these
countries wait for years praying hoping
wishing for something to change and with
this initiative funded by you this has
helped bring that hope to action just
five hundred-pound can transform a
woman's life by setting her up in
business to self generate income which
instantly takes her out of this poverty
trap and provides security instability
for her family I need somewhere secure
to live summer I can work to become
self-sufficient and help my children's
needs and hardships if anyone can do
anything from our family we will be
thankful to you
[Music]